I am willing to take up the office of
first Minister a moment postponed since
elections in 2022 and a milestone in a
far longer history of bitter conflict a
politician who wants to see a United
Island becoming Northern Island's first
Minister we Mark a moment of a quality
and a moment of progress a new
opportunity to work and to grow
together confident in that wherever we
come from whatever our aspirations are
we can and we must build our future
together
for the main though this was a speech
about daily governance about
infrastructure public services and
respect for different communities and in
that Michelle O'Neal had agreement from
the new Deputy first Minister from the
main unionist dup which wants to
preserve Northern Ireland's place in the
United Kingdom Michelle is an Irish
Republican and I am a very proud
unionist We will never agree on those
issues but what we can agree on is that
cancer doesn't discriminate and our
hospitals need fixed
for the first time in years politicians
here may just have captured the mood of
people they were elected to serve
whether it's dup whether Shen and
whatever just work for the common good
of the people that they were elected to
work for there's so much oldness on the
streets NOS being done for them to make
the country work I mean it's a great
place so it is just they need to work
together concerns remain though about
the capacity of the executive to meet
those needs
with both unionists and nationalists
having walked out in recent years people
be watching closely to see how the first
Minister and the deputy first Minister
um work together and present a joint
united
front it will be difficult because of
the Hardline unionism uh that we've seen
in the last two years and the Temptation
on nationalist side to be pretty
Hardline as well in their inaugural
speeches the new first and Deputy first
ministers both committed themselves to
coopera ation and to respect for the
other side but both also noted the
landmarked nature of this moment in
Northern Ireland's long and troubled
history one that still casts a shadow
over its postconflict politics Harry
forcett Al jaaz
Belfast make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer